the crash happened as the Pakistan
International Airlines flight was
attempting to land for a second time
initial reports say the Airbus pilots
sent a made a message reporting problems
with both engines and made a go-around a
few minutes later the airliner came down
in a highly populated residential area
near Karachi International Airport the
horse of Karachi on up and finally the
last words we heard from the pilot was
that there were technical problems he
was told on the final approach that both
runways are ready and you can land but
the pilot decided he wanted to go round
for that reason and what the technical
problem was were good to go and look at
that airplane parts were strewn among
burning homes security forces were sent
to help the rescue operation and managed
to pull at least two passengers from the
wreckage pakistan Prime Minister Imran
Khan tweeted saying that he was shocked
and saddened by the crash offering
prayers and condolences to the families
of the Dead aviation apps identified the
aircraft as a 15 year old airbus a320 it
was one of the first and P IAS fleet to
restart flying this week after flights
were grounded to stop the spread of the
coronavirus crash investigators are
expected to arrive to begin the search
for clues and find out what went wrong
on the relatively short flight of an
hour and 45 minutes from Lahore to
Karachi the crash coincides with the end
of Ramadan normally a busy time for
travelers returning home for the Eid
holiday it's also four years since
another air crash in Pakistan during
Ramadan killed all 47 people on board
via Harding al Jazeera Alaska the latest
now from Kawada in Islamabad Kemal what
more do we know
well we now know that there were 99
people on board earlier it was said that
there were 98 people on board and those
two people of course being rescued and
that also by the first responders who
were the locals in the area after which
the rescue teams arrived but because
this was a congested area with narrow
alleyways leading to the site of the
crash that the military was then called
in with the heavy equipment to try and
cut access into that area it is now
nightfall rescue and relief efforts are
still underway many people are trapped
under the rubble it is feared and most
of the people who have been turning up
in hospital with serious injuries
apparently are the people who were on
the ground at the time of that crash so
investigators obviously now will be
looking at to what really happened in
the final moments after that made a
signal but it appears that the plane was
on in the gliding mode which suggests
that it engines had already gone and
probably that is one of the reasons but
investigators will have to find out the
real cause it is indeed a tragedy this
particular story is likely to remain for
the next 12 to 13 hours because the
rescue effort is going to be difficult
it is nighttime it is Ramadan and people
will be working around the clock to see
if anybody's buried under the rubble of
those destroyed homes thank you for that
come on Haile there live from Islamabad